will CNN become the new Fox News in 2024
many of you have been emailing me about
this failed former president Donald
Trump has been actually suggesting to
CNN listen if you want to pick up on
what Fox News used to be you should
actually become the right wing Network
and people would flock and advertisers
would flock and Trump would flock so
let's actually explore this this is an
interesting media story The Natural
reaction you might be saying Fox CNN CNN
becoming Fox it doesn't make sense isn't
Fox News the conservative Network that's
been dominating for decades yes but
things are changing pretty quickly and
it is true that politics can make some
pretty strange bedfellows so let's
discuss what is going on as you I'm sure
know
Fox News has been the go-to channel for
the American right wing and I'm using
that that particular term as opposed to
for Trump supporters or for fiscal
conservatives or for Republicans or for
whatever the case may be because it's
been the default cable outlet
agenda setting power for the American
right wing and it's where the right got
their news even though much of it was
actually opinion disguised at news
disguises news they got their opinions
they got their talking points but then
came Donald Trump
initially
Trump was not favored by Fox News in the
2016 primary which started in 2015. but
Donald Trump energized a base of support
that included lots of people who were
not previously participating in politics
they were not really in anyone's
audience and to the degree that Fox News
eventually came around and supported
Donald Trump in 2016. Trump's followers
also became Fox News viewers fine
over time after Trump's first term ended
Fox News and the Maga crowd were
increasingly at odds Trump's sort of uh
populist and Confused populist
nationalism
increasingly was not completely in line
with what Fox News was putting out there
although Tucker Carlson is is someone
who was and continues to put out that
populist rhetoric and then the 2020
election big lie led to a bigger Rift
where eventually Fox News got away from
the lies that Donald Trump was telling
we now have learned as a result of text
messages released because of this
defamation suit filed by Dominion
against Fox News that even the Fox News
hosts that early on were pretending as
though they believe Trump's lies about
the election privately we know they
didn't this includes Sean Hannity Tucker
Carlson and Laura Ingram at minimum at
minimum so we now have a situation where
the Trump crowd the Trump part of the
American right and Trump himself are to
put it lightly disillusioned with Fox
News they for a while now have been
looking for Alternatives this includes
for some of them Newsmax this includes
for some of them oan both are to the
right of Fox News and it also includes
even wackier stuff real America's voice
and you know the Lindell TV and all of
these other crazy things but more
recently Donald Trump has been overtly
going after Fox News and he even has
suggested alternatives to Fox News
during his recent CPAC speech he uh sort
of suggested I you know Fox News might
turn my speech off because of the things
that I'm saying Etc so over the last few
months a new Option has been
increasingly floated including by Trump
himself what if CNN
now under the leadership of Chris Licht
who is new president over at CNN who
seems primarily concerned with whatever
needs to be done in order to get ratings
up and to get Revenue up what if CNN
which has been called fake news which
has been called failing CNN liberal CNN
for years what if CNN became the new
home for Trump supporters and maybe even
for more of the American right wing
above and beyond just Trump supporters
in a sense it sounds crazy but it is not
as far-fetched as it seems under new
leadership always interested in what is
our next thing and there have been a
number of recent articles and op-eds and
and sort of uh pleadings from Donald
Trump as well
that CNN could become the new Fox News
or at least a version of it the idea
being if CNN framed itself as we are the
place that are going that we're the
network that will show you both sides
but they use both sides really to give
voice specifically to Maga trumpism
rather than just generically the
Republican party on Fox News it is true
that the more establishment Republican
party people like Mitch McConnell for
lack of a for lack of a better example
still have a very prominent role there
and to the extent that CNN now includes
Republican voices they are mostly
establishment Republican voices that is
absolutely true
so the opportunity would be for CNN to
make a slight shift shift the Republican
voices to be more trumpy voices play
them up maybe put in a little bit of
right-wing opinion there were there were
times when you had more right-wing
opinion uh in a more official capacity
on CNN and then see what happens with
the ratings now I have to tell you
Trump's instincts I think are correct
that there is a desire from the Maga
trumpists for something more mainstream
and by mainstream I don't mean in terms
of opinion I mean in terms of
distribution more widely available the
Newsmax and oan so they don't have to
feel like they're relegated to channel
9000 on whatever cable network right
there's there is a desire for that and
CNN even though the right has derided it
as being liberal fake news for a long
time CNN has taken an anti-trump
editorial approach on many of its Pro
programs but is still primarily a
corporatist News Network so I don't
think it's as crazy as some are making
it out to be the question is is this
something CNN is interested in pursuing
and maybe even more importantly
just because it makes sense from a
business standpoint for CNN to go more
right during the Republican primary and
maybe during the general election
once it's all said and done and we're
Beyond November of 2024
is it still a logical direction for CNN
and that's a real question mark to which
I don't have the answer let me know what
you think is this something that CNN
would benefit from doing do you expect
that they would do it let me know your
thoughts in a comment in an email in a
tweet and then we will follow up
one of our sponsors today is Leisure of
NYC offering Ultra comfortable fair
trade men's clothing at fair prices guys
know it can be very tough to find good
boxers and t-shirts the search is over
because all boxer briefs by Leisure of
NYC are made with amazingly soft
moisture wicking viscose from bamboo
super lightweight like air but it
doesn't Bunch up and it's also great for
the planet Leisure of NYC also makes
really great supima cotton crew neck
t-shirts less than one percent of men's
Basics today are made with supima cotton
it is the best out there it feels like
Silk quite frankly you can walk around
in a scratchy t-shirt all day or you can
enjoy the cloud soft feel of supima
cotton and actually love the shirt
you're wearing these are my go-to
t-shirts and boxers nothing else even
comes close to providing this level of
comfort and all of their products are
fair trade and made sustainably go pick
up the most comfortable t-shirts and
boxers you will ever own but hurry
because they often sell out especially
the boxers go to davidpackman.com
NYC and you will get 15 off with the
code Pacman at checkout and the link is
down below